foreign
welcome to this new video on backward
chaining versus forward chaining by
simply learn to stay updated with our
content make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates imagine you're solving
a mystery in the world of computers
backward chaining is like starting with
the answer you want to find and figuring
out the clues that lead to it on the
other hand forward chaining is like
starting from the facts you already know
and using the rules to uncover new
information both techniques are like
paths that computer take to solve
problems one starts with the goals and
find the path to it while the other
starts with what it knows and keeps
adding to it until the solutions become
clear these strategies make AI systems
smart and capable of cracking integrate
problems the job opportunities in
machine learning are as wide-ranging and
abundant as a technology applications
the average annual salary for machine
learning engineer is hundred and forty
thousand dollars in U.S and in India the
average annual salary is 20 lakh rupees
per annum on that note if you are an
aspiring AIML engineer then there is no
better time to train yourself in
exciting field of machine learning with
our Caltech AIML boot camp in
partnership with IBM this course covers
everything from fundamentals to Advanced
Techniques like machine learning
algorithm development and unsupervised
learning this Ai and machine learning
boot camp in collaboration with Caltech
will help you advance your career as an
eiml specialist the AIML bootcamp
includes the live classes delivered by
industry experts Hands-On industrial
relevant projects and master classes by
caltic professors key features of this
amazing machine learning course include
22 C's from caltex ctme online
convocation by caltex ctme program
director simply run career service helps
you to get noticed by top hiring company
is earn a bootcamp certificate from
caltex ctme industry relevant Capstone
projects in three domains Caltech ctm is
circle membership 25 plus Hands-On
projects across industry verticals and
integrated Labs so why wait join now
seats are feeling fast find the course
Link in the description box so without
any further Ado let's get started what
is backward chaining backward chaining
backward deduction or backwards is also
a reasoning method that acts in the
reverse direction to forward chaining
the top-down approach involves using
decision or goals to reach the facts the
backward chaining is the backtracking
process of finding usage in diagnostic
debugging and prescription here is a
simple real world example of backward
chaining scenario diagnosing an illness
here we have a goal to determine if a
patient has a flu rules and facts
if a patient has a fever and body aches
they might have the flu if a patient has
a runny nose and cough it could be a
cold
if a patient has a fever they might have
infection
if a patient has body aches it might be
due to physical exertion in this example
let's say we start with the goal of
determining if a patient has a flu
so how does a backward chaining process
works look at tool one the patient has a
fever and body aches at rule 3 the
patient has fever look at rule 2 the
patient has runny nose and cough this
rule doesn't apply look at rule 4 the
patient has body aches based on the
backward chaining process the evidence
suggests that patient might have the flu
because of a fever and body aches this
is the chain of reasoning that leads to
the conclusion that patient could have
flu in essence backward chaining starts
with the desired outcome and traces the
path backward through rules and facts to
find supporting evidence it's commonly
used in diagnostic systems
troubleshooting and other scenarios
where the goal is to determine the
causes or conditions that lead to a
specific result moving to the advantages
and disadvantages of backward chaining
advantages of backward chaining backward
chaining offers optimal resource usage
by efficiently concentrating on
essential loss or requirements for goal
achievement resulting in time and
computational savings its goal oriented
commencing from predefined objectives
and tracing back to identify AI relevant
supporting situations or rules
additionally its adaptability allows
easy customization across various
applications showcasing a broad range of
problem solving capabilities
disadvantages of backward chaining while
employing backward training for problem
solving it functions unidirectionally
potentially lacking the ability to
generate innovative solutions or
insights not explicitly programmed there
are instances of limited exploration
where it may yield incomplete outcomes
and Overlook comprehensive solution
exploration additionally conflict
resolution can be challenging with
backward chaining especially when
reconciling discrepancies or clashes
among various laws or facts move to
forward training forward chaining
forward deduction or forward reasoning
is a method involving inference or
logical rules facts for data extraction
it is a bottom-up approach perform
redundant currently to reach the end
point or goals it begins with evaluating
existing information followed by
manipulation based on the knowledge base
the existing information can be as facts
derivations and conditions let's move to
a real world example of forward training
here we have a scenario of diagnosing an
illness we will consider following facts
patient has a fever and patient has body
aches so let's look at the rules
if a patient has a fever and body aches
they might have flu if a patient has a
runny nose and cough it could be a cold
if a patient has a fever they might have
infection so how does this forward
chaining process works start with the
available facts the patient has a fever
and body aches apply rule one the
patient has a fever and body aches
suggesting they might have flu this
conclusion might have the flu becomes a
new fact at this point forward chaining
process has derived a new conclusion
based on the available facts and the
rules the process could continue with
additional rules and facts to derive
further conclusions in in a sense
forward chaining begins with the known
facts and applies rules to generate new
information or conclusions it's often
used in systems where initial data is
available and the goal is to reduce new
information or outcomes based on the
data and predefined rules so what are
the advantages and disadvantages of
forward chaining advantages of forward
chaining forward chaining demonstrates
its efficiency by leveraging existing
facts or conditions to achieve Solutions
potentially resulting in time and
computational resource preservation
compared to alternative methods its
flexibility shines through its adeptness
at tackling various problem types and
its Simplicity of adaptation for
differing goals furthermore due to its
capacity to swiftly deduce conclusions
from a given set of facts or conditions
forward chaining is particularly
suitable for real-time decision making
situations however it's important to
consider the potential disadvantage of
chaining so here are few disadvantages
of forward chaining forward chaining May
exhibit partial exploration leaving some
potential Solutions inadequately
explored or generating incomplete
results the methods limitation is
considering only current facts or
conditions might result in an absence of
a Global Perspective potentially leading
to inaccurate conclusions due to a lack
of broader contextual understanding
furthermore handling conflicts within
forward training especially when faced
with inconsistencies or clashes among
multiple facts or rules can prove to be
challenging now let's see the major
difference between backward training
versus forward chaining backward
chaining and forward training are two
distinct inferences techniques used in
artificial intelligence and expert
systems for problem solving and
reasoning they differ in their
approaches and how they derive
conclusions and available information
here's a comparison between two backward
chaining starts with a specific goal or
conclusion and works backward through a
set of rules and facts to find evidence
or conditions that supports the goal
power chaining starts with known facts
or conditions and uses rules to derive
conclusions or reach goals it
iteratively applies rules to non-facts
to generate new information backward
chaining is commonly used in diagnostic
systems troubleshooting and scenarios
where the goal is to determine the
causes or conditions leading to a
specific outcome power chaining is often
used when the initial data is available
and aims to deduce new information or
outcomes based on that data and
predefined rules backward chaining can
be efficient when goals is known and the
system seeks to establish the reasons
behind goal forward chaining can be
efficient when the initial data is Rich
and the system seeks to infer new
information backward chaining is
typically more directed and efficient
but might not explore all the POS
possible solutions if not guided
properly chaining explores new
conclusions as they have become
available potentially exploring a
broader range of solution but it might
not be detected if not properly guided
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on backward versus forward
chaining I hope you have find this
information valuable do check a
postgraduate program in Ai and ml in
partnership with Purdue University and
collaboration with IBM to upskill
yourself in thrilling field of machine
learning don't forget to check the
course Link in the description box let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced huge success in
their career
you need to keep updating your skills
the course material was comprehensive
and the faculty was extremely
experienced The Faculty was able to
adjust their teaching style in order to
cater to the overall skill set of the
class in the rapidly evolving world of
technology it's important to keep up
Skilling for every working professional
stay relevant continue learning
please ask any questions about the topic
covered in this video in the comment
section below our experts will assist
you in addressing your problems thanks
for watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign